okay um welcome to the ddps seminar
everyone uh before I introduce uh the
today's speaker let me uh go over some
rules and Logistics first of all please
mute yourself during the talk um but if
you have questions you can unmute and
ask questions or use chat room to post
your questions so that we can address
them session at the end second today's
ddps seminar is open to external
audiences uh therefore no classified
discussion is allowed so please watch
out finally The Talk today will be
recorded and uploaded in our YouTube
channel that's about it let me quickly
introduce our speaker today I'm it's a
great honor to host Professor Max
Welling who is a full professor and
research chair in machine learning at
the University of Amsterdam and a Maring
distinguished visit visiting professor
at ctech he is co-founder and um a
co-founder of the startup cost AI in
material CI he's a fellow at the
Canadian Institute uh for uh Advanced
research and the European lab for
Learning and intelligence systems where
he served on the um founding
board his uh previous appointment
includes U partner and VP at Microsoft
research and VP at qualcom technology
professor at
ucfi and he finished his PhD in
theoretical high energy physics on the
supervision of Nobel Prize winner
Professor Gerald right and he then
switched fields to focus on machine
learning and first as a postu at CCH on
the supervision of Professor kerto Kona
and then a postu under supervision of
another Nobel Prize winner Professor
Jeffrey Hinton at UCL and the UC
to uh today Max will talk about is AI
Shifting the Paradigm of scientific
discovery I'm sure we are going to hear
a wonderful talk today um now let me U
ask a informal questions and then move
on to Fun Part uh so today's informal
question is Max um I know that as I
introduce today you've been studying the
physics first right and then somehow
move on to the machine learning and you
must be fascinated by some aspect of the
machine learning that's why you
transition from physics if you can tell
us briefly about how the transition
happens
that thank you very much for the
introduction happy to be here I think we
have people online which are not muted
so and um yeah so indeed so I did my PhD
in two dimensional quantum gravity um
and I didn't quite see that's going to
make the impact in the world um and so I
wanted to do something where I would uh
more imp fact so machine learning was at
that point a budding field with maybe
you know people training models with a
few tens to hundreds of parameters not
trillions as we do now um and so I
started working on that um but um and
that's also the reason ultimately why I
started you know start up like cayi
which is to make an actual real impact
and not just a theoretical impact with
papers I'll talk about that a little bit
today um but ironically I've gone full
circle uh going back to physics Material
Science but also I'm very interested in
quantum mechanics I think the
fundamentals of quantum mechanics and
Quantum Computing um so I won't talk
about that but today I'll talk about
machine learing for molecules and
materials um yeah so I'll start my talk
by um talking about two revolutions have
happened um over the course of sort of
uh Humanity um sort of you know not the
first one but of very impactful one was
the Industrial Revolution where human
labor was being replaced by Machine
labor um and it was uh of course it it
resulted in what we have today but
including all the pollution that this
generated because of course we needed to
drill for oil and gas and other fossil
fuels in order to power the Revolution
and it's that which is
currently oh sorry I didn't know
sorry sorry we have a little technical
difficulty oh there we go back that's um
so we need to power that Revolution with
with with fossil fuels which ultimately
also caused the a large amount of carbon
dioxide in the in the atmosphere at this
point um and so now today uh we are
looking at an information revolution
which is replacing mental human labor by
Machine mental labor if you wish which
is of course the AI Revolution and the
hope is that maybe the AI revolution
could help also clean up the mess from
the uh from the previous Revolution so
here's a little graph uh which is the
carbon dioxide levels the atmosphere
this is 1764 which is the invention of
the steam engine and the levels of
carbon dioxide and um Global temperature
in fact M shown here are rising right
after that um this is my birth year um
so in some sense Our Generation i' say
My Generation has been benefiting from
the fact that we can dig up fosil fields
and use them um and it's also up to us I
feel to hand over the the the world to
the Next Generation in a more clean
State um which is we need to start
removing carbon dioxide from the
atmosphere which is a technology that
currently doesn't really exist at the
scale that we needed so here are some
here's a
graph which shows um some scenarios
which are necessary to stay within 1.5
to 2° it seems you're already at 1.5 by
the way but let's say 2 two or 1.5°
global warming uh which means that we
have to decrease the amount of emissions
in the atmosphere here um and by 2050 we
need to be completely carbon neutral
under all of these scenarios now um I
would say these
scenarios should go down in carbon
dioxide under you know I would say
currently the way the world is moving um
I don't see this coming down at all so
it will hopefully be a more sharp Peak
at some point but we will have to be
carbon neutral at 2050 but after that
and this is basically replacing um sort
of fossil fuel with sustain energy
sources but after that there is a
century or at least half a century but
more like a century of having to remove
carbon dioxide from the atmosphere at
half the rate that we're putting it in
now that technology at that scale does
absolutely not exist but all these
scenarios count on that and so that
needs to be developed in my view in
order to not go into crazy global
warming and so um The Hope is um that
technology and AI can help us achieve
that um and so I think we are at the
cusp of somewhat of a revolution in AI
using AI in the sciences and of course
in this lab um people realize that if I
look at all these photos here which are
all about how AI will help change you
know scientific simulation and stuff
like that so you're all into this I'm
sure um so I sort of identified two
steps for this to happen or these are
basically happening right now the first
step is to replace
pieces and bits and pieces of experiment
to computer simulation so experiments
are expensive and slow and the more you
can do in a computer the faster you can
go through design cycles and and all
that so um of course the compu is
growing
exponentially um and that's good um and
so we are going from basically just
trial and error in experiment to doing
lots of experiments and storing the data
analyzing it maybe with Statistics and
machine learning techniques to a state
where we do all the simulations of the
molecules you know literally the actual
simulation of the molecule in silico so
that's the first step and then the
second step is going from um simulation
to emulation so um so so here's an
example the fluid Dynamic So you you're
a car designer you you test your car in
a wind tunnel I you've already made the
first transition so you're not testing
it in a real wind tunnel but you're
doing it in a digital wind tunnel um and
then when you design your next car you
know instead of just redoing that
process and just going through this same
expensive simulation you could have
stored the data from the first one then
trained the neural network to either
accelerate this particular simulation or
actually directly predict the relevant
properties in other words machine
learning is providing a shortcut for
these kinds of simulations of course one
big challenge is to do it in a reliable
way so that it will actually also if you
go slightly out of the the domain that
you will be able you will have reliable
predictions and so um you know this kind
of revolution is happening across um all
the scales of scientific um research all
the way in particle physics where you
talk about picometers and F seconds all
the way up to astrophysics for Life
years and P years um now in this talk
I'll be touching on two of these but um
I acknowledge this is just a small slice
of where you know what you can do the
first one is simulating molecules and
the second one is about something about
simulating
fluids first a little bit about
molecules why am I very interested in
molecules well um they are basically the
root of everything if you can control
simulate and control molecules um you
can solve a lot of society's biggest
problems of course drug Discovery is one
uh you know Proto cells is another
that are lubricants 20% of all our
energy losses seem to be due to friction
so better lubricants can help there
better catalysts which are of course um
under underneath All chemical
reactions um and then uh you know here's
a here's a process like nitrogen
fixation for fertilizers and carbon
capture which you just mentioned which
is also really
important um okay so now what are the
challenges in molecular simulation first
a little bit about molecular simulation
so what are the challenges in molecular
simulation um so a molecule you know a
very
rough sketchy sort of level is um a
bunch of atoms or ions connected by
bombs plus a you know electron cloud
around
it I do have a clicker but it's I can
okay um now one of the three challenges
for molecular simulation
um so the first one is um basically in
order to evolve a molecule forward in
time is just in principle we think
neonian Dynamics uh which is that the
change in position is given by velocity
and the change in velocity is given by
force the problem the first problem
appears because the force is largely
quantum mechanical due to the electrons
right so this gives you uh very hard
computation to do if you don't
approximate it the second one is this is
a highly iotic system is a highly
nonlinear set of equations set of Odes
if you wish um that needs to be evolved
and very quickly of course this becomes
chaotic and and the third one is if you
want to design materials um the search
phas is humongous because 10 to the 60
at least but possibly larger um and so
how do you effectively search through
the space of molecules and
materials um now here's a few examples
of things um worked at but also where
the where the field of has started to
make
contributions um and so on on this side
we have the time depend shary equation
where the green W is the sort of
electron cloud this is a beautiful
visualization by Quantum magazine um and
here time dependent Shing equation and
then we have you know um ideas to to uh
to take the functional for DFT which is
a functional of the density the electron
density and we and you have to write
down something for that and now people
have started to train machine learning
models for this DFT functional um and
the other one is a Quantum variational
Monte Carlo which is another technique
for solving this equation and uh people
have also started to use neural networks
in Quant in Quant varation M Carlo and
the examples of that are fairet and po
um at one level up we do actually do Lan
Dynamics this is water being simulated
um and you use the l v equation for that
which is again you know neon
dyamics change in position is velocity
change in velocity is given by a
friction term a friction term and a
force term and then random noise and
it's this term which is hard and people
have started to build neural networks to
replace their quantum mechanical
calculation or you typically do it with
the DFT calculation and that's called
The Machine learning force field and
I'll say a little bit more next
so this is something I hope also to have
some time to talk to to you about this
is DFT but for thermodynamics so it's a
DFT calcul method which is Almost
Perfect Analogy of the DFT for quantum
mechanics but then for thermodynamics
again you have to write down a
functional you don't know what the
functional is and because people have
written down rather simple things these
methods didn't work very well but now
you stick in the neural network and now
it starts to work really well and I'll
show you some results and then there's
of course the um you know n equation for
predicting the weather this is a simple
version of it um there's huge amounts of
data available for this which therefore
super you know successful place for
applying machine learning and we've
trained uh when I was the Microsoft
we've
trained um a large model Aurora um to
predict the future state of the weather
um by solving it all as a neural network
not even worrying about the physics we
Native and then there is beautiful
applications um so there's models that
that can generate drug likee molecules
in the pockets of say protein to develop
new drugs um there is the design of new
catalysts to you know accelerate
chemical reactions and quite recently
the paper was published in nature for
the um diffusion models for for
generating materials this is the paper
metagen from um from from Microsoft that
would just generate materials and you
can PR them with certain properties and
they will generate materials for you
there's a so these are all new new
techniques where machine learning is
sort of I would say changing or
disrupting this field of atomic
simulations and search and so he has
sort of Rewritten a little bit sort of a
hierarchy of all the things that you
know people do in the in the chemistry
and and physics Community all the way
from epinal electronic structure method
you know to molecular simulations and
then course graining them to practical
based simulations and of course bring
particle simulations all the way to
classical density functional Theory and
continum methods which is solving PD and
for each one of these there is now a
machine learning method that helps
improve it
right mon Carlo to Quant DFT force field
methods and then force fields for all of
these and then classical TFT where I'll
talk about a bit and these PD circuit
models which are these methods for
weather prodiction and so we are we are
seeing a sort of a real change in this
field where we accelerate the
simulation um by by using machine
learning methods and so now I'll do a a
quick digression because I need some
Concepts to tell you a little bit more
about some of these techniques um so the
first one is symmetries and how to build
them into neural networks now symmetry
is play an incredibly important role as
you all know in physics you can
basically
derive special relativity from from from
a few simple symmetry arguments like the
run and variance and you can derive
maxell's
equations by unifying electricity and
magnet magnetism by basically changing
frames you can turn magnetism into
electricity and back but just moving
observers and and thinking about what
observers see a very powerful tool um in
physics uh you know even even general
relativity can be derived from simp you
equivalence principle that gravity is
sort of the same as it's exactly the
same as duration um and even the
standard model of particles is is
governed of course by by symmetry groups
the different particles are uh different
um you say you can you can rotate or you
can turn one particle State into another
particle state by a Sy
transformation and that s of gives you
the organization of fundamental
particles um so now in in neural
networks though it wasn't very obvious
how to use these symmetries right so you
could train a neural network which would
say predict for me let say the energy
and the forces on
atoms um from you know you give it the
current state of the atom and you want
to predict the forces so you can move it
sort of along evolve it um now it's
clear that if you would rotate a
molecule in space or you would move a
molecule in space it would give you the
same energy and it would rotate all the
forces so that's not an ENT you know you
know if you know the first solution you
just know the second one for a rotated
frame the neural network however doesn't
know about that so it would consider a
molecule input and a rotated molecule
input as a completely different new
problem and needs to learn how to
produce forces for that and the output
if you didn't train it long enough or
with with enough data might actually not
be a perfect rotation and so U with Taco
Cohan and marce Wilder later and a whole
bunch of other students and postdocs we
studied how to take the Symmetry
principle and put it into a neural net
um and the underlying core you know
mathematical idea is this idea of
acarian which says you know here's the
equation but here's the picture that if
you take an input image and um you
translate it and then you convolve it or
just filter it to get you the first
layer of a neural net that should be the
same as fil first filtering and then
translating if you put constraints so
this this closing of this di commuting
of this di put constraints of what the
filters filter Maps can be so if you if
you restrict your neural network to have
this kind of property then you're
guaranteed that whatever you do at the
end has the has the Symmetry property of
the of the group that you're interested
in and so if you're interested in then
this is an excellent book written by
Maurice and you know and other
co-authors but mostly by Maurice I would
say um and um he has beautifully just
written the book in sort of a
hierarchical fashion where the first
chapter is very high level and then it
goes into deeper and deeper levels um
but it's also very richly and
beautifully Illustrated so this is the
perfect introduction into this field if
you're interested in learning more about
this um and so we also worked on graph
neural networks because obviously a you
know an image is a regular you can
represent as a regular grid but a
molecule isn't nicely represented as a
regular GD it's more like a graph where
the atoms are the nodes and then the
interactions are the at the edges of the
graph the only problem is is that it's
not so clear how to do a convolution on
a graph um this has to do with the fact
that um you know in a graph if I just
move a particular node drag it to some
other place and change the order um the
convolution shouldn't change but you the
representation you know if if you don't
take the right representation it will
change and also it should it should be
able to handle an arbitrary number of
neighbors not just a fixed number like
in a regular grp um and so uh we we with
Thomas Kip actually first we developed
this idea of a graph neural network that
is able to send these messages in these
graphs so to do a convolution on the
graph and then later with Victor and am
um we also turn this into sort of more
equivariant version of that so now here
you have a graph you do your message
passing on the graph
um then or Ming or convolution if you
wish then you rotate the molecule and so
now this things if you if you do message
passing and rotate the molecues you
would give you the same as rotating the
molecule and then do the message passing
and so now you have an equivariant model
for graph convolutions on you know that
is fully equivariant and therefore
appropriate for modeling molecules these
are bunch of equations so just to show
this actually have to be complicated so
running these equations to make to get
this to be equi doesn't have to be
complicated so here's two papers that we
wrote um among
others about how to take that idea and
turn us into a force fields right so
this is the se3 Transformer which is a
model that was actually used by David
Baker in his work on um
proteins um Rosetta fold um and
something similar was in the first
versions of alpha fold
um and then another one Ser message
passing for force fields um and so these
methods are completely equivariant and
basically that means that if you if you
rotate in the frame or you rotate the
molecule nothing changes and so what you
see here is over time passing messages
and these are um spical harmonics
representations visualized as you sort
of sending these messages over the over
the
graph um and now the nice thing is that
these machine learning force fields they
sit between aono DFT calculations to do
the forces which are very expensive so
you can only do very small molecules and
uh classical force fields which are
inaccurate but you can do large
molecules and so this machine learning
for starting to span this field so they
can do large molecules but also at the
level of DFT accuracy and there's quite
a few efforts around also in big tech
companies to build these basically
Foundation models for these force fields
which should work across a large swwa of
chemical
space um and of course you know maybe
the main example of why this field is
blooming um is the fact that the Nobel
Prize was awarded to chemists or
biologists computational chem biologist
who have you know both you know solved
the problem or sort of made a huge
amount of progress on a problem of going
from sequence to threedimensional
structure which is Alpha fold of course
or take the structure and design the
sequence that would have that structure
which would be designed probably um and
so you know I think this year's Nobel
Prize is a clear sign that this is an
important field that will deliver a lot
of interesting
results okay so that's for molecular
science and I will discuss a few more
things later a little bit more detail um
there's this other field which which is
also being disrupted or going very
strong with machine learning which is
pte Sol solving and it started you know
this paper by stepen hoer and whole
bunch of other co-authors by basically
taking a usual solver and starting to
look at places where you can replace
certain bits and pieces of it stencils
for instance with machine learn stencil
you could just learn your own stencils
to solve this equation but otherwise
you'll keep the the solver the same you
just keep the same s which is you
improve some of the pieces of it and
slowly that evolved into things which
were starting to remove more and more of
the physics and in particular in fields
where there's lots of data you can
afford to remove the physics and so
there's these deep operator networks and
then there's you for operators these are
all examples of basically removing the
physics um and just training a model
that m into some latent space evolves
the system in latent space as a recurr
neural network and then predicts back
the next state now there's also attempts
of course um to try to bring back some
of the physics and this is this pin
structure phys important neural networks
where um the actual equations of motion
and the um possibly boundary conditions
can all be enforced as regularizers on
these on these solers
um so again U so it's a very fastly go
field here's some of our own
contributions in this field this is a
g&n model where um Bic can have an
irregular grid um you end first end code
for every node in the grid you encode a
a feature vector or token you put them
on the on the on the grid then you send
messages across the grid which makes all
the nodes to communicate with each other
and then you do a f smoothing using a
CNN to predict the next state of the
original model and this we could train
quite successfully on IR regular
crb now it's fun to think about
symmetries here too as we get for neural
networks um it's a bit harder to
actually include them as full
equivariant solvers but one thing that
we could do is we could study for a
particular PD we could study the the
symmetries in fact it's fully solved
problems you can just the lead Point
symmetries you can actually just run a
piece of software you get all the
symmetries out for a PD which I didn't
know but it's kind of beautiful um you
know all these kind of generators for
each one of the symmetries um you can
then represent the group of a product of
these generators um sort of strung
together um and then basically what we
did is we take we took original data and
we started to enhance the data set by
applying all of these symmetries so you
get for free basically data enhancement
and then you can solve this you can
train solvers with much less actual data
than you could
before now I guess there's some big
successes here already going down to
maybe 2016 or something um this was one
of the first papers by Nvidia group um
where what's called forecast net is a
model that um already globally um solved
or sort of you predicted um the next
state of the weather like 10 days ahead
or something like this with these neuro
operators um and then uh fungle weather
came slightly after that these are all
solutions which are completely based on
machine learning there's no no physics
in the actual equations um and then
there's graphc net which is a model
based on um on message passing on a of
hierarchical multiscale graph this is
a so the contribution we made in this
field was called Aurora um so the the
change you what did we do in aor that
was different than before um so it was
made so that the end coder could take
absolutely any kind of data so it could
take data from the US at very high
resolution but local it could take
Global but much more course data um it
could take all sorts of other data in um
it would embed all of that into a lat
structure and then uh basically a
Transformer based encoder and then
evolve that and decode
um so the data set is about over a
million hours of data it was trained in
about you know 38 or something a100 gpus
for I don't know a few weeks so not too
terrible in that sense um it achieved
5,000 time speed up relative to U the
normal solver so that's the big gain you
get you can solve things 5,000 to
sometimes 10,000 times faster um than
the orinal
so um
[Music]
all right and then um so um so what this
particular model could do um the other
models couldn't do um was besides
predicting the usual hydrodynamic
variables like wind speeds and
temperature um it could also predict
things like air pollution concentrating
greenhouse gases Etc so by just actually
keeping the encoders the same and this
fine-tuning the models based on new data
slly um and so it could produce air
pollution with high very high quality
and and what's also interesting is that
sort of the standard ways of the
simulators for future for um so the
weather prediction is ifs
H which you see here and lower is better
on these scures for this is surface
temperature and this wind speed these
machine learning models actually do
better than Americal solers you just
wonder how is that possible since
they're largely trained on maybe data
also from the simulators but in this
case of course it's also real weather
data that's being included into these
models and real weather data can
actually make it better than the
numerical solvers can and much faster so
that so I think that would count as a
true change in the field I've seen
meteorologists from highly skeptical
change to all right we really need to do
something with this because this is
actually changing our
field um and then um I'll talk a little
bit about um some some other
applications of where um AI has been
helping
um sort of the sciences and and also in
the other direction right so it's I've
used symmetries to improve neural
networks um and here physics like uh non
equili thermodynamics is also helping
build better generative models and so
the I would say the error the causal
error goes in both directions and so in
2013 dur King man I developed this
variation Auto encoder
model um and that's a model where you
take a distribution of of data and you
map it into some latent
space and then there the encoder which
is s of this is your semantic
representation if you wish then there's
a decoder which samples from hopefully
something very close to that that
particular sort of embedded manifold and
then inverts the encoder into basically
sampling back from a distribution which
is then approximation to the original
data manifold but it did so in one
stochastic steps it was a complicated
neural network but then noise was only
added at the end and so that evolved
into um these kind of diffusion like
models where people don't train the
encoder so we train the encoder the
encoder is fixed it's just a fixed
process like a orang room process um but
you have many stochastic layers which
gives you embeddings which are not
structured at all they're just
completely mixed um but they but you can
very powerfully train to invert them and
so you can see here an example like a
two dimensional example you have a data
manifold it gets kind of diffused into
sort of a blurry blob and so if you look
at every data you know so it's like a
process where you s of increase entropy
right and then this is a physical
process if you want and then you're
trying to invert that so you're trying
to go from from this BL and generate
back the manifold basically by
generating by training velocity fields
for every point in space you in the
velocity field which is our neural net
and he says if you're here in this space
follow of this velocity field and then
they just put things back onto this
manifold um and by doing this slowly
step for step you can really train very
part from all of the G from there to
there and these authors already
acknowledged that that is actually an
application of ideas of non equili
thermodynamics um and that's a field
that is really developing I'm writing a
book about that I'll sh share a little
bit more later because these connections
between machine learning and
thermodynamics are very very deep
actually in my view um so I would say
that the next step in this this
development was to map the problem from
a discrete problem to a continuous
problem SD governed by Brownian motion
people know how to invert that as a long
KN result you pick up this extra um term
which is a non you know it's a very
non-physical process obviously because
you go against the second law
thermodynamics but mathematically you
know how to invert it you pick up this
term but it's kind of funny because it
depends on the actual density itself and
you don't know it but the machine
learning model will train this so you
train the model to uh to to approximate
that score function and then you can run
the the process in Reverse to generate
images um so here's a few equations then
so um there's a very interesting deep
relationship between machine learning
and U and
thermodynamics um so I guess most of us
are physicists here or mathematicians or
or chemists or something like this
you're probably very used to these types
of equations right this is saying if
you're if you're an equilibrium you know
the you know you have a hamiltonian that
describes your system and you have a
temperature that's connected to the heat
B then the distribution of your latent
variables is actually um you know a a
bolman distribution right where X might
be you know microscopic variables You
observe like maybe the the volume in
which everything sits or something like
that and that are the you microscopic
degrees of freedom of the of the atoms
that's the equ distribution that's Vol
distribution and so you can write down a
free energy which is minus t like the
partion function which you can lower
upper Bound by a variational free energy
with a variational distribution q and
that's given by the expectation of the
hamiltonian under theq minus temperature
ter the ENT of the now if you relx the
system you kick it out of equilibrium
right then Q changes H doesn't change
and you relax it back to equilibrium
then um you minimize this variational
free energy and when Q becomes the
bolman distribution you're back to the
free energ minimum the energy described
by theer function so work is related in
this view by changing this free energy
by changing the hiloni if you start
changing the honi around by applying
forces then you're perform pering work
on the system and the second law of
Thermodynamics follows from the fact
that if you relax this
system then you will find that always
the entropy of the system and the
entropy of the boss which is given by
basically the heat you're generating in
relax relaxing the system back to
equilibrium the sum of those two will
always be positive on average um not for
any any path but on average with very
high likelihood that's going to be
positive and that is the second law of
Thermodynamics basically we go to the
machine learning side we typically write
on posterior distribution we use Bas
rule so we say we have some observation
X you have latent variable Z which could
be the latent variable of some embedding
and We Know by what base rule that's
given by The Joint divided by the
marginal VX and then you can write down
a free energy which was done by Jeff
Hinton and ref while go you can write
down the free energy as minus log of B
which is the probability X of the data
and you can upper bound that by the
variational free energy again with some
variational distribution q and it's
given by the you know the expected value
over Q minus l p The Joint minus the
entr right if you compare it with this
you can just read out that H is minus
log P of the joint and the temperature
has to be set to zero because there's no
real heat B in this case and there's q
and here we have a famous algorithm
which is called the maxim expectation
maximization Al from statistics which
says if I if I want to learn a system I
need to do two things I need to change
the model P by changing the parameters
right that's the M step and that's
performing work because now you're
changing the
honia and the other step is relaxing the
system by changing Q back to equilibrium
which is what we call inference in these
models and that's equal to the basically
execution of the second Dynamics so
these two things match perfectly with
each other and they the same and the
claim is that the mathematics underlying
machine learning probabilistic machine
learning and graphical models is exactly
the same language of non equilibrium
thermodynamics and that means there's a
lot of very interesting results we can
import from non thermodynamics like
fluctuation theorems and all these kind
of
things okay so um here's sort of a
mapping of what's been happening recent
in the machine learning field and my
claim is is basically all around free
energy um there is variational inference
and machine learning and mcmc sampling
those are inference algorithms um
there's reinforcement learning and
optimal control algorithms there's
shinger breaches and optimal transport
these more
mathematical sort of con Concepts but
they're being used a lot in the machine
Learning Community recently and then
there's generative models like diffusion
models and normalizing Flow
and all of these can be understood by
writing down a free energy of this kind
plus assuming that we have Mark of
chains over the latent variable so we
have a we have a generative process that
runs backward in time if you wish it
runs against the second law of
Thermodynamics it's like the
unscrambling of an omelet right you
start with a picking it from a prior and
then moving back to to produce things
which are very low entropy and this is
the for process which you start from a
data point and you slowly deconstruct it
by adding noise if you take these
assumptions then all of these things are
become you can understand this as
basically non equili thermodynamics and
I'll talk a few about a few of these so
clearly um a diffusion model in One
Direction goes from an actual structured
object and destroys it into a blob of
noise right so that is entropy
production basically that's um you know
a physical process if unfortunately this
that's the physical direction we all
disintegrate at some point um but what
we want is going in the opposite
direction right by putting in energy um
and trying to construct structure out of
noise and that's what these generative
models do they go in the opposite
direction of of of the second ball and
you know surprisingly of course by that
kind of thing you can actually generate
images like this and they becoming
scarily good these days is extremely
powerful tool um and but we also use
that to generate molecules you can use
exactly the same idea and say I want a
molecule with these properties Now train
a model that can do that from data also
the simulated data and then you can
generate so this is a real you know real
process that we've trained we can
generate these molecules with these
properties and a met gen is now one a
version of that but actually generates
materials so that idea was also used by
by a especially by these two students
here at epfl um to generate drug likee
molecules in the pocket of a protein
right so you say this is the Propet of a
protein has this shape in fact I have a
few components maybe anchors which I
want to in particular face
places complete the molecule so that it
will actually fit in the pocket and has
the properties that I want um and so
this is a very early version of that
this this is idea has also evolved
already quite a lot
um now we look a little bit of optimal
control and Shing of
bridges so um this project I call
project cfus this is this poor guy that
had to roll a rock up a mountain and
then exactly when he was there it would
always roll back and you would start
again the old Greek mythology um so
that's kind of the fate of a molecule
when it's trying to sample and go from
one metastable state to another
metastable state if you try to do this
by molecular Dynamics in your your
computer it will take insanely long like
the AG of universe 10 times over
something to get there um and so you
need to help it a bit so you need to add
an extra Force to these atoms so that
you can just move it over the over the
energy barrier and get it into the other
side and you can then track it of course
it's a very unlikely event but you can
track it you can study it and then you
can compensate for the fact afterward
that you have added all these forces
um and so that's called uh PA integral
sampling um and so the idea is you have
an initial state for your atoms given by
the positions and now um You Follow
normal L of
vynamics but you add an extra control
term the extra control term is nudging
the atoms in such a way that you go over
you they go change the confirmation or
even have a chemical reaction happening
at that space you move it over the
energy barrier um and that's a
reinforcement problem because you just
give it reward for making that happen in
such a way that you do it at the least
possible total energy expenditure and so
this is a paper that we prod and we
still working on similar ideas here
where this is the free energy landscape
and this is the confirmation of the
molecule and your driving it you know so
that it will get to the other local
Minima um and so here it has to push
over over the energy barrier and then it
gets into the other local so the energy
goes up and then the down and now you
can study these paths and figure out you
know how chemical reactions happen and
what their rates are
instance um so and then here's an
application um on free energy this is a
recent paper that just got accepted in
PRL um so this is this application where
you do density functional Theory but not
Quantum but classical so it's actually a
version
um that doesn't uh it's less complicated
but the mathematics fors extreme follows
extremely similar lines when you write
down the grand canonical potential which
is the sort of free energy but with a
particle B um you write down the free
energy for the
system which only models the internal
interactions so not the interactions
with the external
potentials and then there's a separate
term which in which models the
interactions with some extern potential
could be a molecule that's fixed like a
so if you do absorption you want to get
a fixed external potential you want to
get lots of molecules which going to
absorb and a chemical
potential and of course you have to
write down this thing it's very
complicated because depends on the
properties of your liquid or your or
your gas um and so what we we'll do now
is we'll learn this functional like some
of these approaches in the quantum
version as well we learn that functional
from MD data so it's emulation right so
you generate lots of data like here and
you train the functional neural
network but within the same framework of
theion function the and then once you
have that you can now basically run an
algorithm to minimize this for a new
external potential you initialize it
some row you minimize this functional
and get your equilibrium State you can
even use it to do Dynamics so it turns
out and so here's the method that we
developed in a little bit more detail
um and the the big Advantage here is
that we can train the entire model with
setting all external potentials to
zero why is that uh nice because uh you
basically you can reduce your data set a
lot so the only thing you need is
basically this um radial distribution
function which says you know um if if
you're at the center you know my
molecules have a certain size and
interaction which means that the next
molecule needs to have a little distance
from me which is where this dip happens
nothing can be very close and then you
know since it's packed the next one is
getting you know a high probability
being at that distance Etc this little
you know line basically gives us all the
information we need in order to compute
the two point correlation functions for
this free
energy and then what we do is we do mg
simulations we get our densities of
every grid point with the number of
particles let's say we map it through
Network we do two times Auto diff which
gives us the so we predict the free
energy then take two * out to get the
twoo correlation function we can compute
the twoo cor correlation function in
theory as well using this cornin get
zero and then we compare the two and we
minimize the difference no external
potentials right we're just looking at
things which are flat like a
bulk and we train this and then once
it's trained you can now run this
equation called the peard iteration
which is the same as the self
consistency Loop in Quantum DFT which is
you start with some initial density row
you need the first derivative of the
free energy with row and then you run
this to
minimize the Omega the ground potential
so you're not take a new situation but
with an external potential you stick it
in compute the free energy do one times
order get these derivatives stick them
in this equation and
itate okay and so
um here one dimensional examples where
this is the true um uh sort of density
and here the blue line is where you see
it you know it it equilibri under this
process to find this equilibrium density
we can now do this in three dimensions
as well of course using all the
symmetries of the system we can do this
now in three dimensions very very nicely
as well um and so this this got
published in PRL very recently if you're
interested in reading more about this
but I find this interest what I find
interesting about this example is that
this was not a very popular method at
all nobody used it why not because
people couldn't write down to write
functionals for for the free energy so
they wrote down things which were based
on buer expansions and whatever but they
didn't really work well when neural when
you use a neural net to train that thing
can be much more expressive and now
suddenly these methods really started to
work well it's another example of where
machine learning can really take
something that didn't work very well and
turn it into something that can actually
work very well by combining you know the
strengths of both I would say here some
more results is also very interesting of
course you can predict free entities
directly in one shot um you don't have
to do CL of complica calculations I'll
just skip this for a moment because
we're running a little bit out of time I
think um and so maybe to start sort of
ending a little bit um I I view the sort
of at cusp of a golden age for Material
Science a lot of people focus on jet GPT
and you know AGI and all these things
but I think the more interesting part
I'm sure all of you agreed with me here
I think the more interesting part is
actually applying these ideas to disrupt
the field of of materials and um and
scientific
Computing and of course somewhat
dramatically we've named the ages in
which Humanity should evolv technology
to the actual materials that they use
from Stone bronze iron plastic POS the
narou I would think we going to enter a
phase where we do material over EV you
just tell me what material you want
there's a search engine like you would
not search for information you can
search for materials with those
properties even making sure things are
being synthesizable Etc and it will give
you the answer so that that might
dramatically accelerate the cycle of
innovation um and it's of course you
know the fact that we have these these
these fields which are all our molecular
science these are old and mature Fields
where there's a lot of wisdom um these
are much more young Fields like
computational science I've just heard
you got the biggest supercomputer here
on the site you know that's
computational science machine learning
is adding to that now fast um and and
and changing the field and of course
hopefully the future Quantum Computing
can also be actually the first sensible
application of quantum computing is I
think to similar quantum
mechanics um and then there's all these
applications which are I think real
societal problems that need to be solved
relatively fast around Health you know
could be resistant bacteria antibiotics
against resist bacteria or pandemics or
whatever um sustainability you know
getting carbon out of the atmosphere
energy sector batteries is a great
example there or
hydrogen um splitting so hydrogen
production
using water splitting
Etc um and so this is what we are
building across but the startup that I
was talking about is basically a system
that um uh sort of is built on
generative AI it's gener it's a
foundation model for generating
molecules it then it searches into space
of you know the space of possible
molecules and it builds lots of property
predictors to predict very quickly the
properties or simulate you know the
systems that are being predicted all of
that generates data that go back into a
database in which we then improve our
models and we accelerate this cycle
further and first there's a search
engine around this thing which we tries
to
identify materials which are you know
which people want to use for certain
applications um and so the last slide is
in my view there is a deep connection
building between Ai and the Natural
Sciences and free energies the core
concept that we need to understand um
and we can see lots of cross you know
fertilization machine learning is
helping the Sciences do simulations
faster and better but these Concepts
from science including symmetries and
free energies but also things like
fluctuation theorems and all these
things that are coming out of non equal
thermodynamics they also start to bring
new Concepts to build better Machinery
ons um and so you could argue machine
learning is a new hammer for the
scientist that will develop fast and be
quite powerful um and then maybe the
most important part is that there is
lots of really important applications
that can be solved with this in both
health and sustainability such as you
know developing new drugs and new
materials and um I I'll end there to
some space for uh
questions fascinating um very informal
um excited by the the results you have
done very thankful let's have a Q&A
sessions I do think there were hands
raised up um but before we go into the
online is there any question from the
audience in person yes so what you're
saying is let's say I want a material
that captures carbon dioxide out of the
sky and turns it into a a solid material
are you saying that if those are my
parameters I could you could create that
material and put in as a parameter to
make it the cheapest
possible way possible and yes well okay
how would you train a model right so you
have to break the problem off a little
bit so um let's say so the way we so we
looking for a certain set of materials
called metalorganic Frameworks so that's
a class of materials so you can train a
foundation model for metal organic
framework so that you can simulate them
very fast
um so then um you can and then you need
to find the material the metalogic
framework that
absorbs uh let's say carbon dioxide in
natural atmosphere so where there might
also be a lot of water and other
nitrogen in there um but preferentially
uh you know takes the um carbon dioxide
and binds it um and then also you need
to you need to model how it can be
released um without using too much
energy if you have a simulation pipeline
for for these processes right so you can
if I give you a material you can quickly
using machine learning components
evaluate how good that material is for
that entire process which is you could
be complicated right because it could be
either simulating you know the
absorption process with the machine
enforce fields or maybe predicting like
heat of absorption or other kind of
properties or for vity whatever of that
material directly with property
predictors so your with machiner you can
accelerate it once you have this this
ability to very quickly evaluate a
material you can then start building
generative models that generate lots of
candidates and then start to evaluate
them quickly and of course what you
really want is that when you generate
these materials you want not just random
ones you want the ones that are Guided
by your objective function which is I
want materials with these specific
properties you can do this by either
conditioning the model on that
information like a prompting if you wish
or guiding the generation in the
direction where you think the
interesting materials are as the
generative model gets better and better
it produces more and more sensible
search results or or or molecules which
you still have to evaluate but you sp
that process up too by by Machine
learning methods right and then the
cycle of going around accelerates faster
and faster so that's the whole process
that's being built and that's of course
it's all about how do you do one step in
that cycle one one going around one step
very very fast because once you have
these candid you want to come up with a
list of candidates and go to the lab and
say now please synthesize these right so
you have to think about are they
actually even synthesizable how
expensive are they to synthesize you
know are they actually good materials in
the real world which also have to
simulate you know can you actually put
them in actual machine will they remain
stable or will they disintegrate after a
few Cycles all of these things will have
to be
simulated but then you can optimize
against it in silico in your computer
and by the time you get to the lab you
say now please synthesize these for me
you want a very high probability of
success right so otherwise you have to
go to the lab way too many times and the
cycle slows down a lot yeah so that's
that's kind of the process that we're
pursuing and I think it's a continuous
process process it's not like you flip a
coin you flip a switch and then
everything is perfect it's something
that continuously improves itself over
time as more data becomes available more
experiments have been done um but it is
something that can really accelerate the
field
with yeah so I was kind of interested
halfway through you talked about how we
dropped the physics from the model and
we just train this solely on data it
seems like you know you're throwing out
a lot of the
fundamentals that you kind of know I
guess in some sense is there how would
you I guess it seems like you're missing
some of the physics and maybe you don't
understand it so how could you use that
to basically have a model that performs
better than your base understanding to
increase it rather than just drrive
performance yeah so um that's a great
question um and that only works when you
have a lot of data so in the case where
you don't have a lot of data you want to
put in a lot of
physics in back into the model but what
happens for these um weather prediction
models there's a lot of actual data out
there that's not just generated by by
models right it is actual data um from
the atmosphere if you wish so if you
train your models both on
predictions and from actual data which
is basically what people do so they
basically take these observations which
are of course Very sparse and then you
kind of
interpolate all that data using you know
their simulators to create an initial
State let's say for your model and then
they predict the future that's the new
state and then again actual data and you
correct it again using the actual data
It's a combination of the simulation
which you think is an interpolation
machine and the actual data now you can
see if you train your machine learning
models on that combination you can be
better than the simulator because the
simulator doesn't use the data the ual
observations the simulator typically is
the laws of
physics right and you the initial state
is the actual state of the let's say the
uh you know obtains is obtained by using
actual data but then the actual
predictions are used by just using an
obvious stes equation these models even
in the way that they evolve the state
use the actual data and observations and
so they can actually be better in that
sense now there is a danger to all of
this as well which is if you don't use
physics laws of physics you might get um
when you get into new territory like
you've never
seen you know a very very hot place
before or maybe the CO2 levels are are
so high now at you know that you have
never seen it before like you do climate
modeling that you you could run out of
the regime where you've trained your
models and so
reliability and uncertainty prediction
are really key in this in this as well
so bounding with your physics and then
fine tuning with the actual data that
you
have um yeah I think it can it can both
ways I think it's it's typically good
you mean okay here the example is that
people have now so when you try to put
in a say
symmetries um it seems completely
sensical to put symmetries in and this
is what we've been doing for a long time
but people are starting to throw out
symmetries when the data sets are very
large and the reason is um putting in
all these constraints makes these is
also harder to
learn and so they can actually when you
have a lot of data the models that throw
out all the physics are actually
starting to perform better now right and
so this is something to do with learning
Dynamics I think it you know I think the
pendulum will swing back and people will
say well we can also put the physic back
into another ways and learn well and so
I think in the end it's always a good
idea to put in things like energy
conservation which you really want to
hold um in these models and so there's
certain things which we have to learn
how to put back into these models but
but right now it's really you know it's
a battle between easy ways to train very
very large M and a lot of lot of data
versus being trying to be smart with all
sorts of physics
information and it's it's you know it's
a function of how much how smart you are
with training these models and how much
dat you have
avable
K okay you made a connection between
this machine learning and the non equum
thermodynamics yeah I think it was very
interesting to me do you think this um
our knowledge or physics concept from
the thermodynamics can help us
understanding um the theoretical
background of the machine learning for
example like conversion property of the
neural networks like something yeah so
that's tricky though so I think the
field in physics which is related to The
Learning part is called control
right so so in fact people do try to
control physical systems to do certain
things for them um so that's quite
related to The Learning part um but once
you start messing with a system it's not
just physics anymore right it's like you
know it's like the learning part is less
physical in sense because you're trying
to get something from a high entropy
state to a low entropy State and so
that's less like around what is the the
of physics that can help here the other
direction of course is exactly physics
but that's actually in these diffusion
models uh just backstein process and
it's very well understood however One
Direction which we are going is to think
about you know could you for instance in
the forward
process an orang un process it takes
infinitely long to get to a garan
distribution where we really want this
into a finite number of steps it need to
happen in a finite number of steps
because of the computational resources
you have and so now there
is uh you know there very interesting
work which is called um like Optimal
transport where you can show how to
bring one distribution to another
distribution in a finite amount of time
but you have to apply forces again so
it's it's more like a control system and
then the Hope could be you could show by
the way that that process dissipates the
minimum amount of work is the most
efficient way physically to say change
the distribution into another
distribution or it's also called counter
diabetic
driving um so so now you could hope that
this Theory which tells you something
about um dissipation work dissipation
and heat generation and whatever is
related to let's say variance properties
of estimators and that's actually true
so it's actually true that if you take
so where does he generation come from in
thermodynamics it comes from
fluctuations right if you have the least
number of fluctuations in fact what will
happen is that you generate the least
amount of heat so these fluctuations you
can show will cause variance in certain
estimators let's say of free energy
differences between two states so there
there's a direct relationship between
estimation statistical estimation and
some Physics process and now you can
start to learn you can say okay what did
people do in physics to control systems
to have minimum heat generation could we
use those and the theory around those to
help us design better statistical
estimators and Better Learning
outs thank you there are um I'm sure
there are more questions and also there
are indeed questions from online but we
do have a next schedule to cover so
unfortunately we have to end it right
now but let me propose something uh Max
is going to stay here
onsite the whole
afternoon in this room actually so if
you have want to have a more detailed
discussion with Max I welcome you to
come by uh starting from 1: p.m. um
throughout the whole afternoon so please
come here and for the participants
online um if you would like to you know
engage in the afternoon sessions please
let me know um um so that I can you know
send the WebEx uh the invitation so that
we can you can come and then um engage
in the discussions as well so shall we
do that yeah sound good to me okay well
for the last closing remark let's thank
our speaker today
[Applause]